Gretchen forte is the author of
bootstrapping your business start and
grow a successful company with almost no
money the founder of the gene Forte
Family Foundation which supports the
work of Christian organizations engaged
in education anti-poverty work in
outreach and a candidate for governor of
Montana through his successful career
mr. Jian forte has founded five
different startup companies he began his
career AT&T bell laboratories in 1983 in
1986 he founded brightwork a pioneering
developer of network management
applications in 1997 he started right
now technologies a cloud-based software
company which grew to more than 1,100
employees before being purchased by
Oracle in 2012 mr. Jian forte now
mentors my mentors Montana entrepreneurs
and serves on the boards of several
national and local organizations in
addition he is also a strong supporter
of education and has launched
scholarship programs that aid low and
moderate income students and veterans
mr. Jian forte holds a Bachelor of
engineering and electrical engineering
and a Masters of Science in computer
science from the Stevens Institute of
Technology he and his wife live in
Bozeman Montana please join me in
welcoming mr. gene
thank you very much and it's an honor to
be here at the kirby center of hillsdale
college and i'm joined by my wife susan
we've been married 27 years and we have
four children so Susan thank you for
being here so yeah thank you I would
recently I asked 200 high school
students if they had ever thought of
starting their own business and very few
hands went up their response is really
tragic in my mind yet consistent with my
experience young people are not
considering entrepreneurship as a career
path I had a similar experience with a
class of college business majors none of
whom were considering starting a
business honestly I was shocked at
another two-year college I recently
visited 21 of 23 degree programs produce
graduates exclusively for work in
government and so just to play the
reciprocal two out of 23 programs
produce people for the private sector
without entrepreneurs we would not have
any businesses without businesses we
would not have a private sector and
without the private sector or productive
industries as adam smith term them we
would not have economic surplus to pay
for government education the arts or
health care all that add quality to our
life our free society needs
entrepreneurs I'm a lifetime
entrepreneur i started in junior high
mowing lawns mostly because i wanted to
buy a dirt bike and i use the surplus
then to also purchase a Radio Shack
computer back in the 1970s and with that
trs-80 in high school I started my first
software company a post college as was
mentioned as Jack mentioned that kind
introduction I've started and grown five
technology businesses our latest
software firm rightnow technologies my
wife and I started in our home we
started it with
than five thousand dollars in startup
capital and we doubled revenue and the
number of employees every 90 days for
years all while being cash flow positive
in 2004 that business went public and we
are traded on Wall Street and ultimately
grew to 1,100 employees and was
ultimately purchased by Oracle we
bootstrapped that business using
customers money to grow it and we did
that with all of our other for
businesses as well and i'll talk a
little more about that later but the
important point here is it if we want a
vibrant private sector we need more
young people and people of all ages
aspiring to start businesses I've become
convinced that we over complicate
business startups not that starting
businesses is easy but it's really not
that complicated I recently got
acquainted with a program in Austin
Texas called the Acton Academy
children's business fair and what's
really curious about this program is
they start with six year olds and I
think the parents in the audience will
recognize the fact that that the beauty
of a six-year-old is that they don't
know anything's impossible we seem to
learn that later in life this children's
business fair actually has kids aged 6
to 14 starting businesses and there's
only three rules the first rule is you
must make something the second rule is
you must sell it to actual customers and
the third rule is you must charge more
than it costs at the end of the day
that's the basis of business oh but
there is a fourth rule no adult
supervision and these kids do it on
their own uncontrolled uncontrolled or
unconstrained by adult supervision you
see we really do over complicate
business they've been running this fair
for almost a decade and they have a
hundred student teams that participate
each year and some of these young kids
make over ten thousand dollars in a
weekend we need experiential
entrepreneurship programs like this in
all of our schools to plant the seed of
entrepreneurship in young minds I'm
convinced that entrepreneurship really
cannot be taught in a classroom
entrepreneurship is not a spectator
sport entrepreneurship can only be
learned experientially that's why
programs like the children's business
fair are so important I encourage those
of you who can to start one in your
communities details on this program are
up on the web you can just google
children's business fair now I really
want to drive home this idea that
entrepreneurship is can only be learned
experientially I had a young man come to
work for us when we were about 10
employees and he stayed with us until we
were about 800 employees so he got to
see the whole thing from a front row
seat he left and started his own
technology company and it grew to dozens
of employees so he enjoyed some success
he had experienced our business
firsthand and yet when he came back to
visit a few years later he told me that
he thought he knew what a start-up was
about but until he was actually in the
saddle making decisions day in and day
out he had no idea I remember what we
started our first business I felt like I
was doubling my knowledge about every
two weeks and that went on for years
until you're in the saddle doing it
yourself you really don't understand
what's involved you see ideas are easy
execution is really hard and you don't
really learn about it so you're doing it
again entrepreneurship cannot be taught
in a classroom it must be experienced so
in addition to giving our kids
entrepreneurial dreams and experiences
what else do we knew need to do to
preserve our free market society well we
need to look at higher education as well
I've
I've had the great privilege to lecture
at many top business schools here in the
US and in England and the students
always seem to like my talk but I
actually never been invited back and
it'll be interesting to see how today's
talk goes but I think I'm on higher
ground here at Hillsdale so this should
be okay I believe business schools face
to problems as they try to produce
entrepreneurs the first is they have
become very vocational in there near
exclusive focus on the mechanics of
business courses focus on market
research competitive strategy and
finance but little focus is placed on
the philosophy of business and how
wealth is actually created in our
society essentially what we're missing
is traditional economics can we bring
back Adam Smith as a result many
students have come to believe that
for-profit corporations are somehow evil
or at least less good now don't get me
wrong there are certainly some bad
actors in the private sector and in
corporate America too we could probably
hold a whole other lecture on crony
capitalism and and but that's not our
focus for today I was I was an
entrepreneur in residence last year at a
at a college and I gave a public
entrepreneurial talk in September and
then followed it up with a shark tank
the next night where the students were
able to pitch their ideas and we
crowdsource the best ideas and then I
went back on campus once a month to
coach these student teams through the
startup process and what really shocked
me was that these students really
believed that not-for-profit
organizations were somehow morally
superior to a for-profit enterprise and
this seems to be an increasingly
prevalent view on college campuses the
prevailing wisdom is that somehow
nonprofits are better than for-profit
enterprise and only when I led the stew
through a set of Socratic questions did
they realize that without for-profit
firms they'd have nothing to eat or no
cars to drive no homes to live in and
maybe most importantly no cell phones to
text on my final lecture of the year on
that campus there was on the virtue of
the private sector and the virtue of the
private sector was honestly a new
concept for many of the students that
actually some of the faculty as well and
with these views on college campuses as
today is it any big surprise that so
many young people are embracing Bernie
Sanders I'm encouraged that there's been
growing activity to create centers on
college campuses that promote positive
impact the positive impact of
free-market principles and that we have
places like hillsdale where free market
principles are still taught shouldn't
the virtue of the free market system
though be promoted to all our children
in all of our schools we must regain the
moral high ground in economics or we
will lose our economy we must promote
the virtue of free enterprise as the
only path to prosperity and individual
freedom so the second issue that I found
with business schools is they better
prepare students for work in large
corporations than they do to launch
startups you see if you're or can get a
large corporation you've been tasked
with launching a new division there's
going to be millions of dollars at risk
so by necessity most of the planning
work focuses on risk mitigation and
downside protection cash forecasts
competitive analysis contingency
planning all these sorts of things in
stark contrast when you're doing a
start-up in your garage you generally
have very little at risk so the best
thing to do is try stuff experiment
throw things against the wall and see if
it sticks nothing ventured nothing
gained this try and see startup mode is
exact opposite of what's taught in most
business schools and they're preparing
physically they're preparing kids for
the work in the corporate world this big
company think encourages entrepreneurs
to believe that the first thing they
must do is write a lengthy business plan
and they go raise money I recently had a
man come to me from one of our Indian
reservations in Montana because he
wanted to start a restaurant in his
community and Montana proudly boasts
seven indian reservations all across the
state I've had a chance to visit them
all and mentor entrepreneurs on many of
them and we greatly need more Economic
Opportunity in these communities so
anyway this gentleman comes up to me and
shares his story you want to start a
restaurant there were no other
businesses where he lived but he had
responded to my entrepreneurship ideas
in a seminar he had attended so he did
what most people do he asked me for
money to start his restaurant he wanted
to buy kitchen equipment and he won to
rent a building and so he'd start up his
restaurant well being a dyed-in-the-wool
both bootstrapper I told him there might
be a better way to start his restaurant
so I encouraged him to bootstrap now
bootstrapping is simply a concept of
using customers money to start a
business and as was mentioned I've
started five businesses this way with no
outside capital and lest you think
bootstrapping might slow growth in our
most recent business you know as I
mentioned we doubled revenue and the
number of employees every 90 days and
the whole time we were cash flow
positive that business ultimately grew
to 1,100 people and was publicly traded
for eight years so it didn't hinder our
growth at all so my advice to this would
be restaurant tier on the reservation
was to go down to the bureau of indian
affairs building in town there were
there a bunch of people in the office
and it's a funny thing every one of them
gets hungry every day at lunch time I
encouraged him to go there on a Tuesday
and take orders for lunch on Thursday
and get deposits well
he used those deposits to buy groceries
and then made the lunches in his own
kitchen and delivered him on Thursday he
made three hundred dollars at first day
and that weekend he got a catering job
so again he used the deposit to buy the
groceries he needed he was cash flow
positive the first week not bad he hopes
to ultimately build his business up and
grow by a lunch truck so he can service
the various communities around his
reservation now the MBA would probably
still be writing the business plan
bootstrapping is how most startups are
formed less than 1% of business startups
in the u.s. raise professional money and
yet that's the prevailing wisdom amongst
business to school graduates all will
say you write a business plan and then
you go raise money and yet what they
don't say is that once you get the money
you start a bonfire you pitch the money
on the bonfire and you hope there's a
company there before you run out of
money it's a very high-risk way to go i
lecture a lot on entrepreneurship and
bootstrapping and I've written a book
called bootstrapping your business I've
mentored hundreds of Montana
entrepreneurs and the benefits of
bootstrapping are really tremendous
number one you end up building your
business on a legitimate real-world
value proposition from day one number
two you initiate the critical sales
learning process sooner because you
start with sales ultimately market sales
is just market research where you ask
for the order and you can do that before
you have a product or service three
bootstrapping accelerates time to market
and time to profitability for you'll be
less likely to make big fatal mistakes
because you can't spend money you don't
have five you force yourself into
unconventional thinking because
necessity really is the mother of
invention six you have more freedom and
flexibility particularly related to exit
strategies from businesses and seven
you own much if not all of the business
you create in our last business even
after we went public the employees still
own seventy percent of the business this
created a lot of prosperity a lot of
great outcomes for a lot of people when
i was starting our last firm the first
thing i did was make four hundred phone
calls and back in the 90s when i was
getting started I had a suspicion that
the internet was disrupting how
companies deliver customer service so I
called managers of customer service and
ask them how their business was being
impacted by the internet and they mostly
said the same thing it's these emails
they said this marketing department put
up this website and they've been sending
all the customer service emails to me
and then they lower their voice and say
I'm not answering them because I don't
have any budget to do that well after a
few calls i formulated a proposition and
made more phone calls refining the
proposition as i talked to more people
after four hundred phone calls i had
zeroed in on the essence of a value
proposition that i knew people would pay
for at that point i actually started
writing the software I didn't start
programming until after I knew exactly
what the market wanted and six weeks
later I introduced the first product
customer service emails went down by
fifty to seventy percent for the
corporations that we served and I had 40
paying customers before I hired the
first employee besides Souza to myself
as I mentioned before we doubled revenue
and employees every 90 days ultimately
we were doing online customer service
for two thousand of the world's largest
business to consumer organizations like
nikon in 50 countries american express
and british telecom and were one of the
world's 100 largest websites in terms of
traffic bootstrapping is a lower-risk
faster way to start a business and what
we did was not unique you can be a
bootstrapper it's just common sense and
elbow grease the last topic
want to touch on is government
regulations and the emergence of the
nanny state today nothing seems beyond
the realm of government regulations in
the past year I've done hundreds of 101
meetings with small business owners all
across Montana did you know that if you
get mud on your boots on a construction
site and then walk into the road and the
mud falls off it's not mud anymore it's
a pollutant subject to environmental
impact fines ronald reagan said
government's view of the economy could
be summed up in a few short phrases if
it moves tax it it keeps moving
regulated and if it stops moving
subsidize it that seems to be where we
are given the importance of the private
sector we need to make it easier for
folks to start and grow businesses I'm
not advocating no rules that would be
anarchy however on a continuum between
anarchy and strangulation we're a lot
closer to strangulation today we need
balance every regulation is like a brick
in the backpack of a small business
owner we have abundant public lands in
Montana and we love them dearly every
summer our family would strap on
backpacks and hike up to an alpine lake
with our kids and enjoy the great
outdoors but if you over stuff a
backpack the trip is miserable and you
might not arrive at your destination
every time we add taxes regulation or
increase the cost of health care we're
adding more weight to the backpack of
every entrepreneur in America the load
is very heavy today I met numerous
contractors who used to have crews of 8
or 12 people but now they work alone
because they can't deal with all the
paperwork workman's compensation
insurance and health care costs dictated
by government regulations what is the
cost to our society when we make it
harder and harder to start and grow a
business well less jobs last prosperity
and ultimately less freedom just this
past month I did a regulation round up
in Montana where I travel to 60
communities doing town hall meetings
collecting these regulations rounded
them up
and make to make it ease that all the
ones that make it hard to grow business
we had hundreds of submissions on our
website regulation roundup calm and the
number one item raised was federal
overreach which is a big issue in
Montana the obamas costly power plan
will eliminate 7,000 jobs in Montana and
raise electric rates by over sixteen
percent and even by the EPA's own
estimates the plan will have no
meaningful impact on the environment
interestingly one year of forest fires
in Montana produces a thousand years of
carbon compared to the coal plant we
have in the state yet because of
government regulations again we're not
allowed to manage our forests we just
watch them burn every summer and we
continue to lose temper jobs we've lost
over 500 timber jobs in Montana alone
just the last 12 months plus regulations
have delayed job-creating permits in our
natural resources industry at one mine
in Montana they've been waiting 11 years
for a permit and have spent almost 30
million dollars trying to obtain it now
I don't think we should approve every
permit for mines but we should be able
to say yes or no in less time than 11
years Milton Friedman was right he said
quote many people want government to
protect the consumer a much more urgent
problem is to protect the consumer from
government small businesses are dying a
death of a thousand cuts and we need to
stop the bleeding so I want to do
something about it we're rounding up
unnecessary and burdensome regulations
and then what I'm elected governor of
Montana will put them all out of the
pasture we must make it easier to start
and grow businesses so I'm an advocate
for entrepreneurs and for small business
owners they are the heroes in my
narrative and we'd be well served if
first we encourage young people to
become entrepreneurs secondly advocate
for free market principles in our
education system and thirdly peel back
the regulations that make starting and
growing businesses more difficult every
year I know this is a huge task but we
must undertake it for the future of our
country our founding fathers never
envisioned career politicians yet there
today surrounded by massive regulatory
bureaucracies without an understanding
of the private sector it's a vital
importance to our life and to our
freedoms Susan and I have been
incredibly blessed in our life
consequently I feel a deep obligation to
our country to preserve the American
dream for another generation it's the
sole reason I decided to step into
public service not because I want
something but because I owe something I
love this country and I know we can do
better god bless you and God bless
I understand we have time for some
questions okay great we've all heard of
the many lemonade stands shut down by
the sheriff in the case of your Indian
entrepreneur I was afraid that one of
the bureaucrats at the office that he
asked them if they wanted lunch would
say are you going to cook it in a
regulated kitchen and if not shut him
down so I agree with you completely on
the over-regulation of life that's been
going on maybe you have the answer from
Montana I'm not sure how we have the
answer for the rest of the country well
I I i agree with you I think the
interesting we have just over a million
people in Montana and one of the things
that's exciting to me is it it's
something we can get our arms around and
I hope Montana can be a environment
where we can return back to free-market
principles it's not as big we can get
our arms around it and I look forward to
to affecting that many of them are but
I've also experienced in in Montana
we've been appointing career government
insiders too many of our agencies it's
really been a revolving chair situation
one of things I've committed to is I'm
going to appoint agency heads we've
actually walked in the shoes of the
people they're trying to serve we have
how about this as a crazy idea I'm going
to appoint somebody to our department of
labor who's actually had an employee
which is not the case today right so I
think we can do better my experience in
business has always been leadership
matters Jim Collins said first who then
what and I think that's the right
practice to follow we need the right
leadership in place we have dedicated
state employees but they hide behind
rule books when they don't have a clear
view of what their mission is
well this this will be a little funny
I'll give you some category but wasn't
Thompson Falls and they were really mad
about the chicken tax believe it or not
there's a head tax on chickens it's five
cents so if you own three chickens
you've got a mail a check for fifteen
cents to the state government got to put
a 49 cent stamp on the envelope they
fell in a couple of categories one we
and I think the biggest one that
consensus one was really around the fact
that state agencies have developed a
culture of enforcement rather than
customer service you know Ronald Reagan
said very clear the purpose of
government is to serve the people not
the other way around and we've lost that
view so a big part of it is culture we
have some issues with workman's comp in
Montana we have issues with not being
able to get permits in a reasonable
period of time the paperwork associated
with hiring employees and then retaining
them is overwhelming so it's a death of
a thousand cuts it's not--there's no one
silver bullet and that's why we started
the website regulation roundup calm and
we're collecting them all and we'll
start peeling them back in terms of
kind of a practical way to actually
reduce the number of regulations that we
have one proposal that I've seen at
least the federal level is putting an
automatic sunset on federal regulation
than have them be reauthorized in the
case of the federal government by
Congress do you think that's something
that you could foresee doing in your
state you think it'd be effective or
anything could cause more red tape than
necessary yeah I think sunsets are a
good idea and and many of our
regulations in the state do have sunset
the bigger issue is the rulemaking that
goes on inside the agency if things are
implemented by statute they often have
they often have sunsets associated the
challenge is now you have career
bureaucrats who the solution to every
problem is another rule and the
stranglehold on businesses gets tighter
and tighter we need new leadership at
least in the state level in our state
agencies at a front in terms of federal
issues whether it's the waters of the
u.s. the clean power plan the Endangered
Species Act honestly I agree with our
state attorney general who has filed
suit against the EPA and has filed suit
against the waters of the u.s. you know
we have stays on both of those these are
really infringement of our 10th
amendment state sovereignty and I think
we have common cause with a lot of other
states to push back a lot harder on this
federal overreach the challenge as many
of these rags come with money so we have
to wean ourselves off the federal
subsidies at the same time we push back
so yeah thank you for your talk mr. gene
for take good to see you it's um a
question on the the business side if you
will it seems like you approach this
backwards then maybe many of us have
considered starting a business or
anything like that you're selling a
product in through selling you're
researching before you actually build
that product um how what sort of
questions are you asking your potential
consumer to inform your decisions
because sometimes they may not know what
they yeah it seems that you've done it
successfully five times so yeah so
that's a good question Roger so the
principle shipping and selling a product
are two distinct and separate activity
you don't need to do one to do the other
and that
the premise of bootstrap you start with
selling you don't make commitments you
can't keep but by you Confucius said
you're never in a position to learn
until you're totally confused so step
one is to pick a target customer whoever
that is and immerse yourself with them
if you were starting a local business
you might make a list of 30 people that
are target customers go take them to
lunch just walk in their shoes for a
while you need to find a pain point that
you can actually deliver you know
deliver an aspirin to make the pain go
away the challenge with a lot of
entrepreneurs is someone says they have
a headache and they immediately jump to
brain surgery well that's a big that's a
big thing to say yes to from for a
company that's just getting started you
want to take the aspirin have them call
you in the morning starting small is
better we ended up building a very large
company we are target customer it
started with a premise that the internet
was disrupting the way large companies
we're going to deliver customer service
to their clients and we know that we're
seeing disruptions mobile devices all
these different things changes in rules
create discontinuities discontinuities
create opportunities for entrepreneurs
so you want to look for a dis cannot
continuity in a class of customers where
there's actually money because it's a
lot easier to sell to somebody who has
money than somebody doesn't have money
and then immerse yourself to you
understand what that pain point is and
then don't try and boil the whole ocean
just deliver an aspirin for the
particular pain they have learning
doesn't start until the cash flow starts
because then you actually have customers
you could respond to it's very you have
a vision of this big mountain that's off
in the distance but the path you take to
the summit is not necessarily direct
would you comment on the impact of and
they express it two ways one is the
minimum wage and the other is the living
wage so my belief is anytime we
arbitrarily set a wage higher than what
a market might otherwise determine we're
actually reducing employment
opportunities I think we need to be
working to create jobs that warrant
higher wages not arbitrarily arbitrarily
specifying a higher wage and that is the
issue we have I mean we we have
incredible work ethic Montana beautiful
natural beautiful and quality of life
rich rich natural resources and yet
today we're 49th in the country in wages
only ahead of Mississippi and I've often
said our current governor should be
shipping huckleberry Jam down to
Mississippi just to say thank you
because otherwise we'd be dead last we
need new leadership to actually bring
some understanding of economics to the
state so we can help small business
people thrive
great as wonderful talk oh I was wanting
to let you flesh out some more the
relationship between the two themes of
education and entrepreneurship
entrepreneurship argument was that it
really is based on experience you learn
how to do it but it's clearly related
back to this education question I mean
so many people think that socialism
ain't that bad anymore but somehow that
education also gave rise to this
bureaucratic notion of needing to run
things by rules and regulations I mean
how do we there's clearly a relationship
there between the two things that we
need to combat and push back on and
you've got a lot of in education as well
yeah so I do believe it's experiential
and this is why I'm such a fan of
getting young people involved I mean you
just have to have young people actually
taste the fruits of their own labor and
experience that and and since the
freedom that comes from that and once
you've done that you'll never take it
away from my concern with young people
today as I spend time on college
campuses in other places is there
staring at a hill they don't think they
can get up to the top up so they're
looking for another path and and
honestly it's a it's a hopeless position
as they'll turn to things like
entitlements or whatever it happens to
be as a path for but once someone's
tasted success and felt the dignity that
comes from standing on their own feet
I'll give you a very specific example
there was a we started a scholarship
program for veterans and lower-income
Montanans to get skills in welding and
machining it's not everybody's going to
go get a four-year degree I'm a huge
proponent for trades education this
young man came up to me and he said mr.
G and Forte thank you for the
scholarship it was a thousand dollars
that paid half his tuition to get a
welding certificate and he said to me I
want to tell you that I'm the first one
in my family to ever graduate from high
school I'm 22 years old I'm married and
I have two little girls and he stood up
a little taller and he said I'm learning
how to well so I can put a roof over
once people sense the dignity that comes
from Stan
on the wrong feet being self-sufficient
you'll never take it away and that's why
entrepreneurship at a young age is so
but I've always thought okay so we are
overtaxed and we're over regulated in
terms of taxation that's a bit of an
uphill climb because there are
constituencies for the things that the
tax dollars raised and pay for it but
who besides the people are in the
regulatory state are for the regulatory
state why why is there's not a real
large constituency that is for more and
more regulations so in terms of going
after the regulatory state doesn't it
wouldn't that be an easier objective
given that the only peony constituency
for the regular our regulators well
there is a segment of society that we've
seen every time there's some issue
there's a there's a a cry for more rules
so it I don't think it's just the
regulatory state someone's got to be
able to stand up and make the argument
that the these regulations are actually
a constraint on the rest of us but there
are many people today that are not part
of the regulatory state that are crying
for more rules
well it's it's you know clearly we see
what's happening and this is why I think
we need people that actually understand
economics to be willing to step forward
and serve it's the one of the primary
reasons why I'm running well well
there's two sides to it I think they're
there are those in business who I had
here's a conversation I had recently
with a contractor and he said I said
well what do we do to make it easier if
we be a contractor here in our state he
said well I'd really like to have a set
aside for government contracts that I
can compete with the bigger guys I'm a
medium sized contract and then in the
same breath he said oh and while you're
at it could you make it harder for these
guys with a truck at a toolbox to get
the jobs that I'm bidding on you know so
everybody's got a dog in the fight and
someone someone's got to come back and
and just say listen starting a business
is hard it's a lot of work so suck it up
and get back to work you know and and
earn it I mean that that's the reality
of that so that's more the cronyism I
think there's really two separate things
that the hue and cry for more rules and
then crony capitalism is I want a
special deal someplace well thank you
very much